I consider Paige like a long-lost sister that I never had that I should have had.
The crazy thing is, me and Paige have been so close but we actually have never met.
My mom was pregnant with me...
...and just found out that I had one arm at 20 weeks, I think.
She wanted to find someone else that was experiencing the same thing.
So she went on a website and found Teresa and Paige.
When me and Sarah were born,...
...our parents were sending letters and pictures to each other and stuff,...
...so they became close.
When I first saw Paige, it was like I'd seen a mirror image of me.
When I saw Sarah, it was kind of like oh, this is how people see me.
We'd talk about boys and life, and compare things.
She doesn't really worry about what other people think about her.
She can walk around happily in a short sleeve top.
She helped me a lot and gave me a lot of confidence.
I could tell Sarah things that I wouldn't be able to tell my friends.
I trust her with my life.
We have been so close for eight years...
...but thousands of miles away from each other.
We definitely wouldn't be very close...
...if it wasn't for Skype and how it's brought us together.
Some best friends come and go.
I feel like Paige will always be my best friend no matter what.
It's crazy that we've never met.
We've always dreamed of it, but it's just never happened yet.
I can't believe it.
It doesn't seem real.
You're so beautiful!
So are you!
I'm sure we'll always find time for each other...
...because it's one of those friendships that you don't find twice.
We're like two needles in a haystack that just found each other.